i grew up watching you
that's crazy this is a very surreal
moment to me i'm watching you now so
here we go
like this is it it sounded like a threat
almost i'm watching it i'm watching you
this is very exciting not only that fans
get to watch season two and rejoin your
adventures but also they know that
you're coming back for season three you
guys have got it in the can
it's exceptional it must be cool for you
to know that you're gonna give this to
the fans
absolutely surreal yeah
you know at the end of season one
at the end of season one griffin
um we got quite the twist
a big reveal for anyone that hasn't seen
it i'm not going to say exactly yet but
i can say that you know you get to play
kind of a double
role in a way what's it like
being able to play you know the
character that a lot of people knew from
a lot of the earlier on and also this
really villainous
dude
um you know i've been describing it as
like a sort of like a mixed personality
disorder kind of thing um
where it's the same person but it's
completely wildly different
personalities and uh it's a it's been
really interesting to sort of toe the
line between the two personalities or
sometimes even three and then sometimes
it melds into two
back to one and
um it's been a real challenge you know
but one that i've really enjoyed doing
it's a lot of fun to do that
and also for those who've not seen
season one
what are you doing go watch it
what's the matter with you come on get
on what's the matter come on
but you both get to play these like
it's like really juicy roles helia you
do this villain thing
very very well and it's so fun to watch
i imagine that it's a lot of fun to do
especially together because you guys
have this back and forth that's like
your bickering the whole time but you're
both like the stakes are high right yeah
incredibly yeah it was so much fun um
exploring these characters together and
also independently because
eden is
you know he's the inferior to gabe but
she's got the alpha mindset
so
it's kind of like two wolves fighting
over the prey of what we want and i ha
eden has one way of wanting to do things
and gabe has another but um because eden
isn't an echo and can be
murdered
um she
has to kind of chill and go along with
what
gabe wants
um but we see how that eventually gets
to her throughout season two
now in the trailer we see the creation
of the new key
and we can't give anything away
obviously is there something you can
tell the fans are all fired up about it
about like the possibility for new keys
in season two
um well you know first off if you think
that the locks have discovered all the
keys hidden inside that house you're a
fool
because there's a lot of keys that they
still haven't discovered that they don't
even know exists
um
so those will be some new exciting keys
for people when it comes to i think you
can see in the trailer
that
eden and gabe are up to some scheme and
they're trying to make a key
and
that is a long and tedious process they
find out
and they
make many attempts
just to see if they can do it
and uh it's a it's a journey but i think
uh i think people should be excited to
take that journey with them because uh
so it's you know you learn the history
about keys you you figure out that
they're not so easy to make and how to
make
them what are the best and worst keys to
have like what the most practical key
that you'd be using every day
versus the key that you were like i do
not want to touch this for fear of
who knows what like there's a lot of
consequences here
be anywhere key
i wish
i could have the anywhere key
if i could just be like
go to greece you know bye that would be
great or even just like go to the
grocery store and not have to like you
know
um and the one i wouldn't want to touch
i don't know the first one that comes to
mind is the ghost key i really don't
like ghosts i'm not a big fan of the
whole like
talk to the dead thing i think i've shut
myself down from that
um
and i don't think i would want to open
myself up to being what was it what did
bodhi call it a a
a life a body like a sock like a sock
without a foot and then i don't think
i'd want to do that
i see i am i would agree with you on the
anywhere key as for the key that i
wouldn't want to have i would say the
matchstick key because that it's just
like a lighter just you know
he's like meh
man like i just you know what i lost
match the key i can just buy a lighter
yeah no big deal
that anywhere nobody that's the one
though that's what everybody that's the
one though 100 or the head key the
anywhere key or the head key are
definitely like i have a head key like a
keyhole tattoo on the back of my neck
because i just find that idea so
interesting of being able to put things
into your mind take them out um be able
to explore your memories all that stuff
i just find the head key incredibly
interesting
very cool well i gotta i gotta wrap this
up here i will say though one thing
about the head key
even with like all the blood and
whatever
the grossest thing is the sound of the
whole key i know
that's every time that's it
every time you're not totally there with
you carlos
it has been an absolute pleasure both of
you congratulations good seeing you
thank you so much
great job have a good one pleasure man
nice talking carlos
you